[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous propose de découvrir
Maisons-Laffitte la ville qui compte un
peu plus de 23000 habitants et situés
dans le nord des Yvelines c'est Jacques
Lafitte banquier et homme d'État
propriétaire du Château de Maisons qui a
donné son nom à la commune en la
développant au 19e siècle dans les
années 1830 il a vendu le grand parc du
château pour en faire une ville avec des
maisons de campagne destinées
principalement aux Parisiens fortunés la
révélé de la gare en 1843 ensuite permis
d'urbaniser la ville et d'attirer une
nouvelle population
nous travaillons essentiellement à Paris
[Musique]
depuis de nombreuses années la ville de
Maisons-Laffitte est surnommée la Cité
du cheval en raison de son importante
activité et caisse selon la légende il y
aurait plus de chevaux que d'habitants
dans la commune le champ de course a été
inauguré en 1800 à 78 ce qui stimula les
activités hippiques ici dans la commune
et de nombreux entraîneurs sont venus à
s'installer nous allons justement
rencontrer un
[Musique]
pour commencer cette journée à
Maisons-Laffitte je suis avec Didier à
Prodhomme entraîneur équestre ici à
Maisons-Laffitte alors Didier Prudhomme
quelle est l'histoire et quels ici dans
cette commune les courses hippiques ont
découlé de
petits challenges entre noble qui
faisait courir des chevaux entre eux et
puis des Anglais ont amené la
compétition
hippique et depuis ça n'a jamais cessé
sur maison Lafitte donc c'est une
commune baptisée la cité du cheval
est-ce qu'il y a plus de chevaux que
d'habitants c'est un peu la légende
qu'on dit ici
il y a très longtemps
mais là à l'heure actuelle il y a à peu
près une moyenne de 500 chevaux 500
pur-sangs qui sont en train sur
Maisons-Laffitte et puis vous avez tous
les chevaux de club hippiques vous avez
les chevaux de concours hippiques voilà
et puis je pense que la ville de maison
Lafitte est en partie sur la reconquête
donc
dans quelques années le nombre va
augmenter est-ce qu'il y a des grands
champions équestres qui sont passés ici
à la maison Lafitte vous avez eu plein
d'entraîneurs qui ont gagné des grandes
courses toutes les grandes courses
Auteuil Longchamp l'Arc de Triomphe
c'était à l'époque dans les années
après guerre il y avait entre
3000 3500 chevaux à Maisons-Laffitte et
il y avait plus de chevaux qui
s'entraînaient de côté forêt de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye que dans le parc
maintenant la pression immobilière et la
circulation avait fait qu'il y a eu un
transfert obligatoire parce que c'était
quand même très risqué
tous qui était en ville et on voit
quelques vestiges encore dans des des
des immeubles il reste des box quand on
connaît les structures des écuries voilà
on les redécouvre ça serait une une
découverte amusante à refaire le tour de
ses anciennes écuries la ville est
vraiment marquée hein si je comprends
bien par cette histoire du cheval ici
tout à fait ça a toujours été l'activité
principale il y a très longtemps dans le
parc de Maisons-Laffitte il y avait
beaucoup de pension de famille ou tous
les salariés habités il y avait plus ou
moins
chaque écurie était lié à un
établissement et avait bien beaucoup de
café restaurant boîte de nuit c'était
tout le monde vivait à Maisons-Laffitte
il y avait pas les les voitures et avec
des chevaux donc c'est vrai que c'était
l'activité principale ça allait rester
c'est un petit peu différent voilà on
est rattrapé par les temps modernes et
le cadre pour pour s'entraîner vous êtes
entraîneur équestre est-ce que le très
bon pour pour les chevaux et pour les
cavaliers également
un paramètre important c'est la
proximité de Paris donc on est prêt de
plein d'hippodrome au niveau circulation
c'est beaucoup plus facile que certains
centres qui sont en province d'autre
part on toutes les pistes ont été
restructurées recettes et on a un centre
d'entraînement de haute qualité et je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de projets qui
vont améliorer le
tout ce qui est lié à l'activité des
chevaux de course et des chevaux de
concours hippiques de haut niveau sur
Maisons-Laffitte
[Musique]
il est midi c'est l'heure de se
restaurer direction le restaurant le
pur-sang un lieu emblématique de la
ville de Maisons-Laffitte ici on mange
bien ici on mange copieux et surtout on
est toujours baigné dans cet univers
équestre à table
[Musique]
ici l'ambiance est conviviale et clients
viennent et discutent au bar à côté d'un
feu de cheminée pour ma part j'ai
commandé des rillettes en entrée un faux
filet frites et une mousse au chocolat
en dessert bon appétit
[Musique]
prix du repas 19 euros pour une entrée
un plat et un dessert
[Musique]
après un chocolat chaud comptoir des
deux frères nous remontons l'avenue de
Longueuil pour découvrir l'épicerie de
Longueil créée en 1880 derrière ses
vitrines se cachent une vraie caverne
d'Alibaba pour les gourmands ici on peut
y trouver des fromages fermiers des
produits régionaux de la charcuterie du
chocolat des confiseries mais pour voir
le plus impressionnant il faut descendre
de quelques mètres dans cette cave à vin
presque unique en France on retrouve
près de 3200 références et des centaines
de bouteilles conservées certains
amateurs n'hésitent pas à faire des
dizaines de kilomètres pour trouver des
bouteilles rares
[Musique]
direction maintenant le château de
Maisons-Laffitte à l'origine Château de
Maisons construit au 17e siècle et qui a
une riche histoire le bâtiment est
attribué à l'architecte François Mansart
il a vu beaucoup de personnalités
passantes ces murs en 1651 Louis XIV
alors âgé de 13 ans à profiter d'une
partie de chasse en forêt de
Saint-Germain pour venir dîner dans le
château avec René de Longueuil le
propriétaire nous allons découvrir cet
endroit
pour nous parler de l'histoire de ce
château de maisons catherine mergalet
est avec nous la chargée de
communication de ce château alors
expliquez-nous l'histoire de ce site
alors le château de maison est construit
au XVIIe siècle pour René de Longueuil
qui est au fonctionnaire au Parlement de
Paris il est il est Rita un domaine avec
un vieux château mais de par sa position
il compris il prend des fonctions
de plus en plus importantes au sein de
de la ville et il choisit de faire un
château plus prestigieux il demande donc
à François Mansart qui est le grand
architecte de l'époque le fameux
François voilà et de lui construire un
nouveau château sur ce domaine un
château de plaisance mais également un
château pour y accueillir le roi et
accueillir la cour on va sortir du
château Renaissance et on
carte blanche pour construire
différemment et ce château devient le
château qu'on a juste derrière nous
exactement donc le château de maison qui
va éblouir la cour dès le sa fin de
construction quand on y arrive on
découvre tout de suite à château qui
brille par sa transparence par son
agencement en intérieur qui bouleverse
les habitudes de l'architecture à cette
époque et qu'est-ce qu'on peut visiter
dans ce château
le château se visite depuis les
rez-de-chaussée rez-de-chaussée donc les
cuisines ça débat le premier étage des
appartements de René de Longueuil la
partie un peu plus moderne va-t-on dire
avec la partie du compte d'Artois et
bien sûr le premier étage le laitage
fastueux les appartements du roi et
maintenant les appartements du
condartois et de Jacques Lafitte le
château de maison se visite toute
l'année sauf le mardi il est accessible
en plein tarif à 8 euros pour les
enfants en visite libre on est gratuit
et la gratuité s'applique également pour
les étudiants ou les jeunes adultes
jusqu'à 25 ans inclus
Maisons-Laffitte est aussi une ville qui
a vu passer de nombreuses célébrités
voltaires à ses journées dans le château
de Maisons-Laffitte en 1723 Jean Cocteau
le célèbre cinéaste résidait place Sully
le chanteur Demis Roussos avait une
maison avec une salle de bain démesurée
construite dans du marbre place Napoléon
plus récemment l'imitateur Nicolas
Canteloup vient régulièrement dans la
ville pour faire du cheval et pour les
fans d'Harry Potter Emma Watson la
célèbre Hermione a vécu ici dans cette
ville yvinoise jusqu'à ses 5 ans
[Musique]
bonjour on termine notre tour de
Maisons-Laffitte par un goûter chez la
pâtisserie durant situé avenue de
Longueuil ici c'est un petit paradis
pour les gourmands mais ce qui nous
intéresse avant tout c'est la spécialité
de la maison le Paris-Brest le
Paris-Brest a été créé en 1910 par mon
arrière-grand-père Louis Durand que vous
voyez ici et donc il a inventé ce gâteau
un jour lors d'une course de vélo qui
faisait Paris-Brest Paris et qui passait
pas très loin d'ici puisque la course
passait à la croix de Noailles donc
c'est le carrefour qu'il y a entre
Saint-Germain Poissy Maison-Laffitte et
donc il a décidé ce jour-là d'inventer
un gâteau et de le faire rond en forme
de roue de vélo
et de l'appeler Paris-Brest
[Musique]
bah c'est le premier donc c'est le
meilleur
bah c'est une autre spécialité si vous
voulez donc une crème pâtissière avec du
pralin avec notre tour de main c'est le
gâteau de mon arrière-grand-père qu'on a
toujours fait comme ça depuis plus de
100 ans depuis qu'il a été créé et bah
c'est le coup de main de la maison
Durand et les gens viennent chercher le
vrai Paris-Brest à Maisons-Laffitte
[Musique]
ça y est j'ai craqué pour ce Paris-Brest
à 4,80 je vais goûter un peu pour voir
s'il est très bon
et il est il est très bon je vais en
prendre un petit peu merci
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce bienvenu à
Maisons-Laffitte j'espère que vous avez
passé un bon moment dans cette cité du
cheval moi ce que j'ai adoré ici c'est
l'histoire et le calme de la commune je
vous laisse avec quelques images de ce
manège implantés ici à l'entrée du parc
depuis une quarantaine d'années c'est
parti et à bientôt
[Musique]